[Music]
in most zelda games the world map would
fill in automatically as you entered new
areas but even prior to breath the wild
some games like maduro's mask and the
wind waker already experimented with
different methods to uncover the map
gradually in this case through npcs who
are designed in a way that they stand
out and are easy to spot from a distance
the shika towers essentially served a
similar purpose with the added bonus of
acting as a fast travel point and due to
their size and the fact that they emit
an orange or blue glow they catch your
attention from pretty much anywhere on
the map when it comes to the sequel to
breath of the wild the footage we've
seen so far shows that the shika towers
as well as the shrines and the divine
beasts seem to be a thing of the past
even the sheikah slate has eluded us so
far causing many including myself to
believe that link's new spectral arm
will serve as the replacement for
hyrule's first smartphone at least when
it comes to link's new abilities but the
shika slate also doubled as the game's
excuse for the map and fast travel
mechanic as of right now we don't know
if we need to unlock the map of the
surface all over again in the sequel or
if this will only be reserved for new
areas like the sky and the underground
many have theorized about regardless if
the towers and shrines are truly gone
there needs to be at the very least a
new system that can replace breath the
wild's map function as well as its fast
travel points which were conveniently
spaced out all across hyrule which
brings us to the zone
[Music]
as much as the zone i have become a meme
in the zelda community at this point it
doesn't change the fact that there's
still plenty of reasons to believe that
something related to them will play a
role in breath of the wild too whether
it's the abundance of zonai architecture
seen in the first teaser the dragon head
mounted on link's shield and even the
green glowing arm could very well be
connected to them in some way still to
make the video more bearable for some of
you and to distract you from the fact
that this is a zonai related theory i
will mostly refer to them as the
backstreet boys for the remainder of the
video because similar to the zonai they
too are a relic of an age long forgotten
and if you're wondering why i own one of
their cds well it's because
shut up i just do alright let's not get
into details here despite that
disappearance the backstreet boys left
behind a lot of interesting architecture
and one of them in particular could be
of more significance in the sequel that
being the towers there's something very
peculiar about these structures not just
the fact that we know next to nothing
about them but if you've read creating a
champion you'll find that the towers we
see in breath of the wild weren't
actually supposed to look like this
instead of stark and basic columns the
original designs all feature a prevalent
and stylish dragon motif similar to some
of the other structures like the mazes
and some of their statues what's even
more interesting and equally confusing
is that the in-game version of the
towers have decorations on them that are
not consistent with the barbarians of
farren and thanks to the efforts of
others like lorulian historian it has
since come to light that these ornaments
are linked to the hylians instead if you
visit hyrule castle more specifically
the hallway leading to ganon's cocoon
you'll find pillars that have identical
decorations on them the overall design
of some of the pillars is also quite
similar to the towers a hexagonal shaped
column which gets wider at the very top
this has led some to believe that the
towers are actually supposed to be
hylian made and that some of them like
the ones in fahren could have been built
on top of older pre-existing ruins
there's definitely a case to be made
that these towers are indeed of highly
in origin despite the fact that four of
them are found on the outskirts of
farren the majority are actually located
in central hyrule close to the wetlands
in the age of calamity dlc we are given
the opportunity to visit gopanga village
a hylian settlement situated in the
wetlands and which was destroyed by
ganon's army in breath the wild's
timeline there's only two towers left
standing in the wetlands themselves in
breath the wild but as you can see in
age of calamity there were actually a
lot more of them all across the village
and not only are these in pristine
condition without moss and ivy covering
them but they still feature that same
hylian crest even if you don't accept
age of calamity as canon whatsoever it's
still a bit strange that the majority of
these towers are found in central hyrule
which is not considered to be backstreet
boy territory by any means there's no
other ruins related to them in this part
of the world and on top of that places
that do like taiflo ruins for example
don't feature any of these towers but as
is often the case with zelda theories
there's also a different side to the
story things that contradict the hylian
tower idea first is the obvious fact
that despite the inconsistency in the
decorations creating a champion does
still refer to them as zonai towers
regardless and second there's one
specific tower whose location raises a
lot of questions this outlier is found
inside the hebra mountain range it's
already a bit unusual to find them in
such a remote location but what's even
more strange is that this one is half
submerged in the middle of a lake this
implies that it was built before the
lake was formed and also means that this
entire waterfall probably didn't exist
yet which i can imagine is a very long
time ago while there are ancient hylian
structures that are as old if not older
than those made by the backstreet boys
the decorations on these towers are
modern hylian not ancient hylian ancient
hylian ruins have ornaments in crests of
their own some directly copied over from
skyward sword which is a neat little
touch and well as you can see none of
them match with the ones from the towers
instead the tower crest falls in line
with the style seen at hyrule castle
which i consider to be modern hylian
it's also worth noting that the hylians
weren't really all that active in the
hebra mountains aside from a wooden
cabin which looks to have been built
post calamity their closest settlement
was tabanta village which is still a
long ways away from the mountain range
at the very least we can say that the
hylians didn't have any stonework in
this area no garrisons or statues or
anything like that but you know who did
the backstreet boys not only do we find
one of their mazes here but they also
constructed two stone doors leading into
the mountains which feature their
recognizable serpent engraving so there
was definitely some activity here all
this conflicting evidence makes it kinda
hard to put a definitive stamp on who
was responsible for the construction of
the towers but you know what it's very
much possible that none of this even
matters because the more i looked into
it the more i get the impression that
the towers we ended up getting in breath
the wild are not the ones nintendo
initially wanted to include in the game
and are instead quick and dirty
replacements i find it highly suspicious
that not a single design we find of them
in creating a champion even comes close
to what we ultimately see in game they
are much more detailed and as mentioned
before they all have a clear motif
related to dragons now a lot of the
concept art in the book actually
features notes from who i presume to be
one of the lead artists most of these
are feedback and requests to make
certain changes and one of the artworks
has these types of notes attached to it
asking the artist to change some of the
details it really seems like they had a
pretty clear idea of what they wanted
the towers to look like so how did we go
from this a fully detailed dragon style
tower which actually coincides with the
building style of the tribe who made it
to this a boring pillar with zero
connection to dragons and a crest on it
that doesn't even belong of course the
easiest explanation would be that they
simply ran out of time and took a
pre-existing model changed it up a bit
and slapped it into the game as a
replacement the 3d modeler responsible
may have even forgotten to replace the
texture hence why the hylian crest is
still there alternatively they could
have concluded that the fancy design
seen in the concept art would stand out
too much and detract from the shika
towers i mean it's clear from the size
comparison alone that they were supposed
to be a whole lot bigger than the ones
we ended up getting but what if there
was a different reason what if they left
out this design because they wanted to
save it for a future story implication
perhaps dlc which may i remind you
breath the wild 2 was initially intended
to be there's several hints that breath
202 story events will have some sort of
connection to the ancient dragons as i
discussed in my previous video they
often disappear into a portal in the sky
and in the sequel we see a sky realm
that seems to be invisible from the
surface at the end of the second teaser
zelda's lullaby is played by the same
instrument used for the dragon's music
theme then we have these enigmatic robot
creatures who also feature elements of
dragons and of course has mentioned
before all the zonai related stuff a
tribe who had a clear fascination with
the ancient dragons particularly farage
who makes frequent appearances in the
farren region and yes i'm calling them
zonai again from now i think the joke
has kind of run its course anyway what
i'm trying to propose is that the zonai
were well aware of the sky portals as
well as the existence of the skyroam and
they themselves may have even found a
way to travel between the surface and
the heavens by constructing magical
towers not only are the zonai described
as having been powerful magic wielders
but the description of the towers
themselves state that they said to have
been used for magic purposes a statement
like this doesn't just come out of
nowhere and in fact nothing in the
actual game suggests that the towers had
magical properties for all we know they
were simply yet another ancient ruin
with a chest on top and nothing else we
know that the writers of creating a
champion were given a pretty extensive
insight into the ideas and thought
process of the zelda team it's how they
got access to all this concept art notes
as well as quotes from the developers
themselves in fact the book reveals
quite a lot of details that are never
actually seen or mentioned in the game
itself and couldn't possibly have been
known unless the zelda team itself
informed the writers about it like how
the guardians emerged from the columns
at hyrule castle during the calamity an
idea which was actually used in age of
calamity two years after the book was
published as such i think it's plausible
that the zelda team had bigger plans for
actual magic zonai towers but weren't
able to implement them because of either
time restraints or because they simply
didn't fit brethwald's story at the time
and might have been put on the shelf for
later story wise i personally think they
would be very fitting i find it quite
fascinating how the original tower
designs depict not only dragons but
specifically dragons pointing up towards
the sky almost as a representation of
their ascent into the heavens the zonai
could have constructed these towers not
just to honor the dragons but also with
the purpose of traveling to the heavenly
realm and the so-called magic they used
could be related to link's new ability
seen in the second teaser where he
ascends rapidly and then phases through
the floor of one of the floating islands
i actually made an entire video devoted
to this mechanic where i explained some
of the details based on information
inside one of the patents issued by
nintendo inside the patent it says that
in some specific scenarios the ability
can be used to reach locations very very
high up basically without a height limit
i theorize that this is how we'll be
able to travel between the surface and
the islands in the sky and i also
mentioned that there might be something
akin to pedestals on the surface by
which we can do this well what if these
towers are going to be exactly that i
noticed that one of the designs has a
disc shaped platform on top divided into
rings and i don't know about you but to
me this looks eerily similar to the
platform we see links standing on in the
new footage here too we see a circular
floor design with multiple rings also
notice how in the background we don't
see clouds or a blue sky but rather what
seems to be a landscape it's obviously
very blurry due to the camera's focus
and it could very well be one of the sky
islands but what if this platform isn't
in the sky but instead link is standing
on top of one of these new zonai towers
on the surface and it's from here that
he'll be able to use his new ability to
travel further up into the skyrim of
course that does beg the question if
these towers do indeed exist where are
they why don't we see them in breath of
the wild nor in the sequel footage well
the latter is quite obvious since
nintendo is known to hide or emit
certain things from their promotional
material i mean just look at how they
purposely left out terraco from the
first age of calamity trailer as for why
they weren't in breath the wild well my
best guess would be that they are
probably hidden on the ground similar to
the shika towers and that at some point
in the story they will emerge from the
earth either all of them simultaneously
or maybe we need to activate them one by
one it could even be one of the
objectives of going on the ground to
begin with by traveling below ground and
activating a new tower there it'll rise
up to the surface and doing so will
grant access to new islands in the sky
which were previously unreachable not
only would it be a great way to connect
the underground surface and sky but it
also allows the developers to obstruct
certain parts of the sky in a natural
way a way for the player to unlock new
areas bit by bit instead of making every
location accessible from the get-go like
in breath of the wild so to recap i
believe that these are not the quote
unquote real zonai towers and that the
ones we see in creating a champion are
and might show up in the sequel as both
a replacement for the shika towers as
well as a way to travel between the
surface and the sky if this ends up
being true it would be yet another case
where nintendo's future plans are hidden
inside their concept art just like we
see with link's arm as well as the
broken master sword anyway that's enough
zone i for one video i want to quickly
let you all know that in the coming days
i'll be making a community post in which
i will describe the details about the
100k subscribers special which as always
will have audience participation i'm
running a bit behind on it so i
apologize for that but i really wanted
to make this video first now that that's
done i will be working on the special
starting next week so i hope you look
forward to that again be sure to check
out the community post if you'd like to
have a chance to join in a big thanks as
always to my discord mods and to those
who support the channel financially you
are all the best and that is all for now
this is dawn signing off and have a good
one
[Music]
you